well bailey ober still looking for his
first big league win in six starts he's
got excellent control only six walks 26
strikeouts anderson manchada and abreu
and chicago's first inning
and upstairs a high fast ball for strike
three
so anderson strikes out that's the 27th
strikeout for ober averaging 10
punch-outs per night and that'll bring
up mankato
and upstairs again gets a swinging
strike three
one two to abrillo
and the pitch is a swinging strike three
on a shoulder height fastball in 93
and a great start from over striking out
the side there's dylan season for his
17th start he's looking for his eighth
win his era in three and three quarters
103 strikeouts in 81 and two-thirds now
he's going to try to get a slider on the
inside
and he does for strike three two gone
polanco will come up
to first jose abreu nice play by jose
and that will do it alex kirilov leading
off the second for the twins
to center hit well goodwin back and it's
off the wall
and carol off continues to sting the
ball that one hopped over the wall
for an automatic double
so strong the ball just kept on carrying
dropped the barrel on it great extension
on that swing some lead off extra base
hit and now kepler
driven to right and deep and
gone
a 2-0 slider kepler is hormone now at
back-to-back games and the twins take a
two-nothing lead
looked like he went off speed on it but
left it up and kepper didn't miss it boy
he starts heating up that's good
number eight and it's two to nothing
twins
wins for the lead off man on for the
second straight inning and here is luisa
rise
loop to left that'll work
simmons round second he'll hold up there
so simmons to second arise with the base
hit to left here come the twins two on
nobody out larnica strikeout victim his
first time up
headed towards the seam and he found a
scene simmons around third he'll score
larnick with an rbi single and it's
three to nothing anderson played on the
shortstop side opening up some space
between the back of the second baseman
garcia and larnick found that hole and
drives in a run and here's polanco all
for one
nice change up for strike three
picked a good time to break it out
that's a big first out one two is a
breaking ball for strike three curveball
got him strikeout number five the 3-2 in
down goes kepler swinging on a curveball
so the twins only get one and c strikes
out three and the twins leave two both
in scoring position over back out for
the fourth moncada abreu goodwin do up
three breaking balls and abreo just
tosses his bat away i think he thought
that was the third out and it's only the
second out
ober delivers curveball hit up the
middles can be fielded by simmons he'll
take it nice job there by bailey over he
wants a couple and strands him we go to
the bottom of the fourth inning stocks
have one hit so far against bayley ober
74 miles per hour we've seen a fastball
at 94. hitter shaking his head didn't
think so but two-hour walk to garcia now
here's tim anderson
right side that is indeed a hit
garcia on his way to third
and now monkat is the tying run and tim
keeps his hitting streak alive
shoots it through the right side
this is a hanging slider this really
shows you for one of the few times
tonight ober is starting to get fatigued
because that slider early was his best
friend and he wasn't missing with any of
them he's gotten mankind twice once
striking out the other time a grounder
to first
driven to right
kepler back five shutout innings for
bailey over
nice job bailey over five innings just
two hits he walked three
and tied a season high seven punch-outs
field bar here will be facing hitters
three four and five abrill leads off
as jose drills this ball left field and
welcome to the ball game the minnesota
bullpen that is a third deck job
for jose abreu and it's three to one
second straight game of the home run for
jose
jose was the happiest man in the park to
see ober out of there because he fanned
him twice
and this time he got a hold of a
breaking ball and i mean he hit every
stitch of it one down now granddaugh
oh two check swing
and yes oh boy he has hurt himself on
the swing and that is not good at all no
cause this one this one exacerbated i
think what happened to him before
and
boy if that is a calf or an achilles
that's a big problem and he is in
tremendous pain oh my goodness
that's monty grandall is down
he's just come back off that calf issue
and
on that check swing it looked like
whatever it was let go and yasmani
grandahl in substantial pain with that
left leg zach collins going to end up
coming into the ball game
there's a fast ball theobar finishes the
strikeout two away and that'll bring up
gavin sheets and the pitch swung out of
miss got him nice job there by caleb
theobar
did give up the big time home run to
jose abreu and then struck out the next
three
so in this inning cease with a hit
batter a wild pitch and a walk there'll
be two aboard four suno
strike three on a slider that is a huge
pitch
for the first down of the sixth inning
mick gordon two at bats against cease
tonight two strikeouts
driven to center field
and all the way to the wall
kira loft will score
kepler will score
gordon flying to third
a two-run triple
this is his first career triple
and nick gordon he can run a little bit
but hit in a great spot they had good
ones shading a little bit
into left center field jay's fry comes
on
it's a four run game
up and in to the backstop and gordon
will score
wartved squared the pitch under his chin
and collins couldn't catch it
and it's a three-run inning the white
sox two on nobody out larry garcia
hitting right-handed
on the ground up the middle into center
field on a two-strike hit for garcia two
runs are coming home and the sox with
nine outs to go are within three runs in
minneapolis so the sox have two one with
nobody out from okada
breaking ball hovered in the zone and
monkatta slashes it right down the chalk
in the right field
garcia's home easily tim's following him
there and yowan is into third it is a
two-run triple and here come the sox one
run 90 feet away
from ty in this ball game
resilient doesn't even begin to describe
it
it is nice ryan burn look at his numbers
14 innings no runs only two hits
here's kepler
driven to left and hit well vaughn back
to the track
it's gone to the opposite field
kepler's second tonight
just his second career home run to left
field
well with that kind of speed from ryan
burr
all you have to do is get part of the
barrel on it which max kepler did
quite a resurgence in the last couple
games for max kepler so runners out the
corners one out runner goes the squeeze
is on the bun is down so no's coming
home burr doesn't throw to the plate he
throws to first for the out
so workvent makes seconds to nose scores
on the squeeze and the twins take an 8-5
lead so it's a three-run lead for hansel
robles it is a save situation chopper to
third step on the bag arise on target to
end the game
and robles gets the save and for just
the second time this year the twins have
beaten the white sox